IN THE PLAYOFFS THAT CONNOR
THE ONLY ONE THERE TO TAKE IT IS
RYAN NUGENT-HOPKINS. THEY'LL
GET A CHANGE AS JESSE PULJUJARVI
NOW TKACHUK COMES OUT.
IN.
>> Craig: YOU SAW HIS HEAD COACH
DARRYL SUTTER AFTER THAT GOAL,
OVER THE BOARDS AS IT'S PUT
AROUND BY KULAK AND FLIPPED AWA
AN OUTLET FOR McDAVID AT CENTRE.
HE HAS CECIE.
AND HERE'S DRAISAITL, HOLDING
ON. LOW.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE WASIGHT, AS H
TO DUCK PAST THE CHECKING AND
GUDBRANSON UNABLE TO GET BACK
INTO THE
THERE'S TANEV ACROSS.
KYLINGTON WILL SEND THAT T TO F.
>> Chris: LINDHOLM TRIED TO
PLAYOFFS.T
THIS IS ONE THEY NEED
>> Craig: THIS IS A MUST SCORE
LINDHOLM BACK TO HANIFIN. A
QUICK RELEASE BY LINDHOLM.
THAT'S NOT AN EASY SHOT TO MAKE.
LITTLE CRADLE AND SERIES ■EVEN
FLAMES AGAINST THE STARS.ND, TH.
HE HAS KEITH BACKING UP OFF THE
AND MAYBE THE SAVE AS GAUDREAU
WAS GOING HARD TO THE NET.
TOFFOLI TR
GOALTENDER FROM IN TIGHT.
AN
>> Craig: COUPLE OF KEY PLAYS,
ONE A GREAT
REMAINING IN THE DARNELL NURSE
PENALTY.
OIOI SECOND PERIOD
FROM THE
BOUNCING PUCK, AND SMITH
DIRECTED THAT
TYSON BARRIE ACROSS.
IT'S THE CAPTAIN WITH
>> Craig: HOW ABOUT THAT
SEQUENCE, YOU HAVE A G
WAIT BACK.
>> Craig: MIKE SMITH ALMOST
PLAYED IT IN THE NO-PLAREBOUND
HANIFIN AND A HIS
NET AND NOW CHRIS TANEV WHO HAS
GUTTED IT OUT ALL
NUGENT-HOPKINS AWAY.
INTO AN AREA ALMOST TAKEN 3 AGAS
ANGELES.
THIS ONE IT BACK.
AND BOUCHARD IN BEHIND HIS
BOUNCING PUCK, BACK TO HANIFIN.
SHOOTING, AND IT GOES
NUGENT-HOPKINS, TWO FOR KANE,
PLAY